all right well we have the full Alabama
Senate race breakdown Roy Moore loses in
a shocking upset ruby-red Alabama turns
blue for doug jones and will explain
just why and whom ought to be blamed i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
another shocking shocking election
result this time out of Alabama where
Roy Moore the front-runner the
Republican in a state that went 97% for
Jeff Sessions in the last Senate
election has now gone blue Doug Jones is
your new senator from Alabama he is a
hardcore Democrat whole caucus with
Chuck Schumer he's a pro-abortion
Democrat and that is not because Doug
Jones is a good candidate that he won
there are a lot of lessons to be learned
from what happened last night in Alabama
Republicans are gonna need to learn them
or they're gonna get their asses handed
to them in 2018 it really will be that
simple but before I get to any of that
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at zip recruiters so
you're looking for somebody to fill a
particular job need at your company and
you can go on a thousand message boards
and try and find somebody you can try
and put out a classified ad or you can
you zip recruiter and start getting
qualified people in your in basket
virtually right away with zip recruiter
you can post your job to over a hundred
of the web's leading job boards with
just one click then zip recruiter puts
it smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates
about your job within minutes of posting
so you receive the best possible matches
that's why super croute is different
unlike other hiring side zip recruiter
does not depend on the right candidate
it's finding you and instead goes out
and finds that 80% of employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day it's
one of the reasons why we use zip
recruiter here at the daily wire you
must use zip recruiter if you want the
smartest way to hire again zip recruit
comm slash daily wear allows you to post
a zip recruiter for free you get to try
it out dudes if recruiter dot-com slash
daily wire again that zip recruiter
dot-com slash daily wire make sure that
you check it out if you're looking for a
great employee this is the best way to
do it zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire it is indeed the smartest way to
hire use that slash daily wire so they
know that we sent you as well okay so I
want to give you the full drama of
yesterday because it was a dramatic day
in politics it began with a bunch of
battery on the part of the Roy Moore
campaign so first Roy Moore arrives to
vote and he decides that it is necessary
to underscore that he is a true Alabama
man how do we know this because he
arrived on horseback to vote I mean not
like he wants to be stereotypical or
anything he shows up on horseback to
vote even Laura Ingraham who's been
backing more in this race so far as I
can tell I even Laura Ingraham said this
was not exactly the smartest
the funniest thing I saw was this video
of Roy Moore arriving to vote on
horseback and somebody cut under it the
music - Blazing Saddles so it doesn't
work I won't say that there's no real
passenger seat for the okay more
arriving for the vote okay and then it
got worse for remote here's the the
first lesson to be learned from what
happened in Alabama last night where Roy
more narrow narrowly narrowly lost to
Doug Jones I mean like lost by 20,000
votes out of a hundred out of 1.2
million votes cast something like that I
the first lesson we learned is there is
a line for voters there's a point where
voters just will not show up for you now
the line for what you'll vote for gets
raised by the impact of the election so
let's put this way this war if there's
been a dog catcher election no one shows
up to vote for Roy Moore it's Senate
election so 600,000 people show up to
vote for Roy Moore if it's a
presidential election then you can be
Donald Trump and you can win because the
stakes are so high at that point that
people are gonna show up regardless
because they feel like they must show up
out of necessity but for a Senate
election even for a presidential
election there's a line beyond which
Americans are not willing to go Roy
Moore across that line it really is that
simple he was an unpalatable candidate
from the beginning before there were any
of these allegations about the the
sexual molestation of underage women
before there were any of those
allegations that had even broken it was
known that Roy Moore was not a popular
candidate in the state of Alabama he'd
already lost I believe the Senate
primary to somebody he'd been tossed out
of the Supreme Court twice he had been
running a narrow race with with doug
jones before all of those revelations
broke and every two days he would say
something utterly insipid or there would
be a clip of him coming out from four or
five years ago and when she said
something utterly insipid yesterday his
spokespeople did not do him any favors
in their final pitch they were making
comments like this here is one of the
Roy Moore spokespeople asked whether he
thinks homosexuality should be illegal
see think look at homosexual conduct
should be illegal it's a it's a yes or
no question probably he probably thinks
homosexual conduct should be illegal and
what would the punishment be for a man
having sexual relations with another man
or a woman having sexual relations with
another woman
what should the punishment be it's just
a sin okay okay so again ladies i agree
by the way as a biblical jew I believe
that homosexual conduct is a sin I also
believe breaking Sabbath is a sin I
don't think the government should be
involved in enforcing either of those
things that was not the moment that
everybody was going nuts about yesterday
in the lead-up to this election here was
Roy Moore spokesperson who was talking
about Roy Morris position that Muslims
should not sit in Congress or be able to
hold elected office this was a stunning
piece of video I mean just like is if
this was the best that Alabama had to
offer on the Republican side it's no
wonder that Roy Moore is not sitting in
the Senate dodged more has also said
that he doesn't think a Muslim member of
Congress should be allowed to be in
Congress why under what under what
because you have to swear on the Bible
you and you you when you are before I
had to do it I'm an elected official
three terms I had to swear on a Bible
you have to swear on a Bible to be an
elected official in the United States of
America he alleges that a Muslim cannot
do that ethically swearing on the Bible
you don't actually have to swear on a
Christian Bible you can swear on
anything really I don't know if you knew
that you can swear on a Jewish Bible oh
no I'm sure I'm sure you've picked a
Bible but the law is not that you have
to swear on a Christian Bible that is
not the law you did you don't know that
all right Ted Crockett I don't know I
know that Donald Trump did it when he
when we made him present because he's
Christian and he picked it that's what
he wanted to that's we wanted to swear
out on Ted Crockett with the more
campaign good luck tonight thank you so
much for being here yeah that not not a
good look for your closing argument I
don't know why you'd have slim pickins
as your actual campaign spokesperson and
just seems like a mistake to me but this
is the first lesson is you can't just
run anyone and hope to win okay Roy
Moore was a crappy candidate the reason
we won more
last night was not because of write-in
votes it's because no one showed up to
vote for him he turnout on behalf of
Doug Jones in Alabama he won Doug Jones
won 94% of all the votes that Hillary
Clinton won in a presidential election
Doug Jones won last night in Alabama 49
percent of the votes Donald Trump won in
Alabama went to Roy Moore meaning that a
lot of Republicans stayed home because
they just didn't like Roy Moore they
didn't like what he represented they
didn't like all the allegations about
him and they were not wrong to do so
okay you present crappy candidates and
they're gonna lose it turns out that the
quality of your candidate still matters
and railing against the wind suggesting
that it's the it's the fault of people
who stayed home rather than the fault of
the candidate or the people who
supported that candidate is just
ridiculous and it's tiring to me this is
this is this backstabbing net legend
that you're getting that the dogs false
leg and the the nonsense that you get
from from Steve Bannon and company that
oh is just that Roy Moore was stabbed in
the back and that's why he lost maybe
Roy Moore lost because there were
credible allegations that he was
molesting underage women and trying to
date people at the food court maybe he
lost because he was really bad at this
maybe you lost because he couldn't win
an election for his to save his life on
a statewide level before this basically
the idea that this was all because there
are a bunch of people who are just out
to get Roy Moore isn't saying you think
I wanted to lose a seat in Alabama you
think anyone who's a Republican in
Alabama wanted to lose that seat to Doug
Jones are you kidding me it's not about
that it's about you got to present a
candidate that earns people's votes Roy
Moore didn't earn people's votes the
laws and political gravity still applied
that's a lesson number one lesson number
two don't follow Steve Bannon down the
primrose path like Steve Bannon knows
what the hell he's talking about I've
never seen someone botching election as
badly as Steve ban and over at Breitbart
news just botched this sucker and not
just bash this he's basically waving a
frying pan around all of us were saying
dude don't wave that frying pan around
you're gonna smack Trump in the face
then he smacked Trump in the face with
the frying pan then he goes well if you
were just more Pro Trump this never
would've happened say well maybe
shouldn't wave a frying pan around in
the form of Roy Moore you dunderhead Roy
Moore was being very heavily pushed by
banning in the last days Bannon was
going to Alabama and saying things like
Mitt Romney's family has less honor in
all of its DNA than Roy Moore has in his
little finger he was going to Alabama
and suggesting that elitists from the
outside see famines from New York and
for a Goldman Sachs and Harvard Business
School in LA and he's showing up in
Alabama wearing his homeless man coat
suggesting that he was the great avatar
of the people who's gonna speak now on
behalf of the Republicans against the
establishment and Roy Moore was on Steve
ban and yesterday his show on Breitbart
news that no one listens to it'll have
more listenership to his Breitbart news
radio show being played on mine than he
will actually having his own show here
is Roy Moore on bandhans show yesterday
before I let you go what was this
campaign about what his campaign was
about truth about right about what this
nation was founded upon what we must
return to to have the nation again
behold and I think it's it's we've got
to get away from this politics of my
party and go good put principle over
party yeah if there's somebody who puts
principle above everything I'm sure that
it's Roy Moore and I'm sure that if
someone puts principle of everything
it's about its it's certainly Steve
Bannon who's the greatest charlatan
political charlatan and con man and
leech I've ever seen in my life and the
media have turned Steve Bannon into some
sort of great avatar of the people some
some face of trumpism without Trump it
doesn't exist
President Trump takes D Bannon off your
cell phone it's a waste of your time to
call Steven and the man does not have a
channel to the people he's not
representative of your base your base
did not show up to vote for Roy Moore
Roy Moore didn't earn half of what you
earned in Alabama you mr. president
the idea that you're calling Steve
Bannon for advice on how to act about
Alabama it's ridiculous you have better
instincts than Steve Anand did you put
Luther stranger in the primary who would
have won this election by 80,000 points
okay in the general in the in the in the
second primary runoff
you backed he backed Luther strange as
well there Luther strange would won this
race walking away in the general
election once these allegations came out
your first move was to basically go
hands-off that was the right move Steve
Bannon somehow must have convinced you
to jump back in with both feet then get
the RNC to jump back in meaning these
smear yourself with mud you get it all
over yourself and all over in the RNC
and then you lose the Senate seat anyway
and this has real ramifications stop
pretending that Steve Bannon knows what
the hell he's talking about
Steve Bannon leeched on to Sarah Palin
then he leeched onto Andrew Breitbart
until Andrew died then he took over
Andrew Breitbart power position at
Breitbart used that to leech onto Donald
Trump and has now ridden that to this
perception of power that he does not
hold all the while writing checks with
his mouth mouths that are cached by the
murse that are that are paid for by the
Mercer family
Steve Bannon does not have the ear of
the American people he does not have the
ear of the base and Trump needs to get
away from this okay take him off your
cell phone all bandhans out there for
his Steve Ben and he does not care about
the Trump agenda if Steve Danon cared as
much about the Trump agenda as I care
about the Trump agenda then he wouldn't
been backing Roy more you had been
urging Roy Moore to get out of the race
as soon as these allegations hit human
urging Trump to urge Roy Moore to get
out of the race when these allegations
hit he would've been urging Trump to
tell Jeff Sessions to go back to Alabama
and run for office there he had been
moving to get Roy Moore out of a race
where one more was going to lose to a
Democrat instead Steve Bannon Warren's
glorify himself at the expense of the
quote unquote establishment and
establishment by the way in the form of
Mitch McConnell who has been moving
along with Trump's policy agenda this
entire time yeah I don't like Mitch
McConnell either I think Mitch McConnell
is a squish in many ways but I'll tell
you what it's not Mitch McConnell's
fault that Trump's agenda isn't passing
through Congress Mitch McConnell is
trying to pass Trump's agenda through
Congress he's doing a lot more for
Trump's agenda and Steve freakin Bannon
as leave Steve Bannon at the door this
idea that Steve Bannon is leading a new
Trump is movement is nonsense
he never was the leader of a movement
the Tea Party pre-existed Bannon and
pre-existed Trump Trump pre-existed
Bannon and Trump will outlive Bannon as
well this should be the death knell of
the idea that Steve Bannon is some sort
of political genius because he clearly
is not I mean every move that it is
possible to make wrong he made wrong
here they first he endorsed mo Brooks in
the primary that was alright you know I
was okay with that I also thought mo
Brooks what it was that was the proper
guy in the primaries but then he but he
said back Roy Moore / Luther strange and
the runoff and then after my more recent
allegations he encouraged more to stay
in the race and then he convinced the
president to put his own credibility on
the line on behalf of a guy who's
running a neck-and-neck race in 66
percent Republican Alabama just well
what what what a genius he is what a
genius and by the way drew helping to
drive up Democratic Democratic numbers
up the wazoo
I mean the numbers last night are really
scary for Republicans and I'm gonna
discuss that in just a second what the
fallout means for all this and a couple
of other lessons first I want to say
thank you to our sponsor is over at my
Patriots apply so here's the reality if
you want to protect your family you're
in a situation where you look they're
natural disasters huge wildfires in
California there there's situations from
abroad where the North Koreans now have
the capacity to hit the United States
with with a weapon at virtually any time
anywhere
whatever the disaster it is you're
worried about you can basically
we ate a lot of your fear by simply
having a survival food kit yep they're
102 serving emergency food kit for only
99 bucks we can for 99 bucks you're
basically ensuring the safety of your
family the folks in my office have tried
this food they tell me that it tastes
just like home-cooked and you can get
this 102 serving emergency food kit for
99 dollars at 888 803 1413 that's eight
eight eight eight oh three 14 13 or go
online to prepare with Ben's comm
prepare with Ben's comm the kids include
breakfasts lunches dinners they're
shipped for free
my Patriot supply those are the folks
you should trust again eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 or prepare with
Ben's comm prepare with Ben's comm make
sure that you're prepared in case
anything bad should happen okay so a few
other lessons that I want to give you
about Alabama first of all Democrats
today are celebrating their over the
moon they think now they have sort of
the reverse position that Republicans
had before this election Republicans
thought before Roy Moore that they could
literally run anyone and it would work
out just fine right Democrats now think
that they think they can run a
pro-abortion advocate in Alabama and win
if they think this they are stupid let's
put it this way incredibly accused child
molester almost became senator in
Alabama okay if the Democrats had any
brains at all they'd be running pro
lifers in place like Alabama you know if
Doug Jones had been pro-life that he
would have won this election by 10
points but the Democrats are so foolish
that they're becoming more and more
homogeneous in their in their viewpoint
and when they do that they prevent the
capacity for their candidates to win in
purple and red states they're hoping
that turnout wins all but I'm not sure
that's gonna be the case so that's a
lesson for Democrats out of all of this
it is worth noting by the way the
Democrats are going to be
extraordinarily hungry in 2018 the
statistics from Virginia Alabama these
are grim for Republicans heading into
2018 I'm looking right now at how
special elections have shifted so far
this year okay the California 34th
district has moved 18 points in favor of
Democrats Kansas 423 points in favor of
Democrats Montana is special election 15
points in favor of Democrats Georgia
sixth District six points in favor of
Democrats South Carolina fifth District
sixteen points in favor of Democrats
even the and then the Alabama Senate
race of course moved 31 points in favor
of Democrats on average the special
elections are moving 16 points in favor
of Democrats the generic congressional
baloff ballot for 2018
currently has Democrats up 10
points ten points okay and it's gonna
get worse from there if Republicans
don't stanch the bleeding the idea that
Republicans can just rally behind Trump
and that's gonna be enough I don't see
the evidence for that here's the reality
about President Trump it makes a
difference whether you are Pro Trump or
not in a primary election you can't win
a primary in the Republican Party unless
you are at the very least not openly
anti Trump right Jeff Flake is learning
that the hard way but when it gets to a
general election allegiance to Trump
doesn't carry a whole lot of weight
right Roy Moore tried to tie himself to
Trump's hip it didn't help him one iota
and Gillespie in Virginia tried to tie
himself to Trump did not help one iota
Trump does not have coattails now that's
not about Trump okay that's not unique
to Trump Trump is not a popular
president but that's not unique to Trump
Obama didn't have coattails and he was a
popular president while Obama was riding
in the 50s his party was losing a
thousand seats across the country Trump
is riding in the 30s with a good economy
and a soaring stock market and he's made
very good political moves over the last
couple of weeks in terms of policy I
don't really see how tying yourself to
Trump is necessarily a winning strategy
if you're a Republican in a general
election I just don't see that it's
gonna matter a whole hell of a lot so
Republicans should take that to heart
and Trump should understand but this is
not about ego at this point if he wants
to retain Congress if he wants to retain
the Senate he's going to have to
actually work hard to ensure that other
Republicans win whether they endorse him
or not Republicans now are on the verge
of losing the Senate it's hard to lose
the Senate but losing Alabama is a good
way to start right they now have 51
votes in the Senate that means that if
they lose Jean Halloran Nevada which is
a significant possibility all they have
to do is lose one more seat and they'll
lose control of the Senate you don't
know where that seats going to occur you
don't know where a can that it's gonna
blow up now Democrats have 10 seats that
are up in red states this year it's
gonna be interesting to see if they're
able to hold any of those now or if they
hold all of them but the momentum is
clearly with the Democrats going into
2018 and Republicans should know that
Republicans should know that so in just
a second I want to talk a little bit
about more of the fallout here
presidents from tweeted his
congratulations in this clearly was sort
of a ghost written tweet on bet on
behalf of President Trump you can tell
by the punctuation those congratulations
to Doug Jones on a hard floor victory
the write-in votes played a very big
factor but a win is a win the people of
Alabama are great
and the Republicans will have another
shot at the seat in a very short period
of time it never ends hey that's very
true Doug Jones is not going to be
senator in Alabama longer than four
he will be gone as well he should be
he's a Democrat
it's Alabama he shouldn't be the senator
from Alabama the only reason he is is
because of this fluke where Roy Moore
one of the worst candidates in the
history of modern politics was running
for a Senate seat in a deep red state
that was not the only thing that Trump
tweeted he came out this morning he
tweeted again and he suggested that it
was all about the write-in votes it was
really not all about the write-in votes
it was about time it was about
Republicans staying home Roy Moore by
the way says that he's not gonna concede
yet so he's just gonna stick around
bothering people but this race is over
nobody is gonna stick around for the
recount he's toast here here's Roy Moore
saying that he's not going to make a
concession I really want to thank you
for coming tonight and realized when the
vote is this close that it's not over
and we've still got to go by the rules
about this recount provision and that's
what we've got to do is wait on God and
let this process play out I know it's
late
we can't wait and have everybody wait to
have to 11 o'clock but the votes are
still coming in and we're looking at
that but god bless you as you go on may
give you safe journey and thank you for
coming tonight
which not over and it's gonna take some
time thank you okay so that means
nothing he's toast we're not gonna see
any more forum or he has done in
national politics as well he should be
one of the other takeaways in terms of
the the blowout among Democrats I mean
Democrats really showed up to vote in
major numbers here is that the black
vote in Alabama was extraordinarily high
so one of the reasons that Hillary
Clinton lost in 2016 is because black
folks did not show up to vote for
Hillary Clinton if they trade up to vote
for Hillary at the same rates they voted
for Obama she would have won in a walk
they did not they did show up in Alabama
last night thirty percent of the
electorate in Alabama last night was
black that is a an extraordinary high
percentage a lot of that is driven by
the politics of race it's driven by the
the alienation a lot of black voters
feel with the current Republican Party
young people if you look at the votes in
Alabama among young people they went
heavily for Doug Jones this is a serious
problem for Republicans they're going to
have to win over new people this was one
of the questions in 2016 in 2016 can you
get enough of the base out to defeat
Hillary Clinton and the answer was yes
but barely and you lost a popular vote
if you are going to win in 2020 you're
going to have to pick up somewhere in
the neighborhood of 10 million
additional votes just to be competitive
in the next presidential election in
2018 you're going
to pick up new audiences you gonna pick
up young people the polls aren't showing
it you gonna pick up black people the
polls aren't showing it we were told
that done that president Trump was gonna
pick up a lot of these crowds he hasn't
spent a lot of time cultivating those
crowds it's time for Republicans to get
on their horse they can't sit on their
laurels they can't assume every election
is gonna be one just because President
Trump pulled the rabbit out of the Hat
and somehow defeated Hillary Clinton
that's an accomplishment it's not a
strategy there is a difference a
president Trump beating Hillary Clinton
was a massive accomplishment all credit
to President Trump but it is not a
strategy
Hillary's wildly unpopular presidential
elections are not midterm congressional
elections all of this makes a difference
now what you're gonna see today is a
bunch of people trying to spin away from
blaming Steve Danon trying to spend away
from blaming the people in the primaries
who voted for Roy Moore though which
would be a mistake sean hannity is
trying to blame Mitch McConnell of
course this is gonna be the convenient
answer this is also bannon's plate
rambling Mitch McConnell is though if
McConnell had come out more strongly in
favor of more more would've won as
opposed to more as a crappy candidate
here's the reality I don't wanna get on
Shawn's case here but I've been on
Shawn's case about this for a few weeks
or at least I mentioned it a few weeks
ago Shaun said that if Roy Moore did not
show him that he was innocent or any
evidence that he was innocent that he
would tell Roy Moore to step out of the
race within 24 hours
Roy Moore provided no such evidence and
Shawn instead backed off of that and did
not pressure Moore to step out of the
race at all Moore stayed in Moore lost
Shaun blames Mitch McConnell I don't
think this is correct but meanwhile what
this last election was about in 2016 is
the forgotten man and forgotten women
that need jobs that are on food stamps
in poverty and they want a shot at the
American dream also so if that is the
Republican strategy I mean it is it
almost takes my breath away and it also
goes I think Mitch McConnell has a lot
of culpability in all of this I was a mo
Brooks supporter from day one I'm
nombres Brooks nearly 30 years he used
to fill-in in my radio show and I had a
show in Huntsville Alabama and I thought
he would have been a great candidate the
person that came out strongest against
mold Brooks Matt was Mitch McConnell hey
so Mitch McConnell let me be clear
Mitch McConnell does bear some
responsibility for supporting Luther
strange in the primary and killing mo
Brooks in order because he thought that
in the runoff
Luther's friends would do better against
Roy Moore obviously a bad miscalculation
on the part of it from college
doesn't have clean hands here but the
idea that Mitch McConnell bears the
clearest culpability here is just not
true it's just not true Republicans are
gonna have to understand that just
because we want something to be true
does not make it true just because we
want it to be true that every that that
trumpism is a strategy and not just an
accomplishment it doesn't mean that it's
true and just because we want it to be
true that we are going to be able to
pull a rabbit out of every hat that's
not true either there's gonna have to be
an actual change in how we look at
things new voters are gonna have to be
brought into the fold I think President
Trump is capable of that if he can keep
himself under control if he stops
calling Steve ban and if the Republicans
actually pass some legislation for God's
sake if any of that happens then I think
that the blowout can be averted I still
think Republicans will lose seats in
2018 but doesn't have to be a blowout
I'll talk a little bit about the stats
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our friends over at
stamps.com
so the holidays are always the busiest
time of year you probably just don't
have time to go to the post office to
mail your presents to everybody this is
where stamps calm comes in really handy
go-to stamps calm and when you go there
and you and you use Shapiro at the top
of the homepage click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage
you got a four week trial plus postage
and the digital scale what Samsung does
basically allows you to be a post office
from home now you can weight your mail
you can determine how much postage to
send and you can print out the proper
postage on a piece of paper cut it out
stick it on your mail print it on a
stick or print it directly onto the
envelope you can do any of those things
and then you can mail the stuff directly
from your home you don't have to go to
the post office you're running short on
time you really don't have time to stand
in line at the post office even if you
love the post office stamps calm
obviates that need it brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips again buy prints
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer and then the
mailman picks it up and as I say right
now if you go to stamps comm and click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro you will
get a four week trial plus postage and
the digital scale with no long term
commitment against stamps comm promo
code Shapiro is a perfect time to try
this out because you're gonna be mailing
stuff I know you are right I mean we're
running up to the deadline Hanukkah has
started last night and we are running up
to the deadline on Christmas so if
you're sending presents now is the time
for you to try out stamps calm and use
that promo code Shapiro lets them know
that we sent you as well so here a
little bit of the stats about 2018
people are trying to use the single data
point of Alabama in order to demonstrate
what
exactly.the what exactly the Republicans
should expect in 2018 I think that's a
little bit an overreach but this isn't
off your election and off your election
since World War two the party in power
loses on average 25 seats Republicans
currently having 23 seat majority pay in
2006 2010 2014 the last three midterm
elections the swings have been
incredibly large at this moment the
generic ballot shows Democrats with a
ten point three percent lead in the Real
Clear Politics average at this time in
2009 Republicans led the generic ballot
by three to four percent and they ended
up blowing that out to a 7 percent
advantage in the 2010 elections and they
ended up picking up 60 seats in the 2006
cycle Democrats led by 9 to 10 points
with the year to go they ended up
flipping the house - none of this bodes
well for Republicans in the House of
Representatives now there are a couple
factors that are militating against
Democrats having a blowout year one is
as I say the bad cycle for Senate
elections the chance that the Democrats
win the Senate even in this environment
are relatively low I would say probably
20 to 30 percent I would have said
before about 2% now I think it's about
20 to 30 percent if you look at but I'm
ballparking it if you look at the house
elections there are 23 seats right now
that are Republican seats in Clinton
districts the chances are that a lot of
those swing away from the Republicans
but Democrats also have 12 seats in
Republican districts so it's very
possible that those swing away from
Democrats it's not clear-cut that
Democrats have as easy a road to winning
the house as Republicans did in 2010 or
as they had an increase in 2014 the
reason being a lot of these districts
have gotten both rhetoric and blue or
meaning that the districts are more
polarized but Republicans are gonna need
to make some moves here that means
passing this tax reform plan now that is
on Mitch McConnell you wanna blame
McConnell for something that one's on
Mitch McConnell pass some legislation
some president Trump to go out and stump
for that tax reform package it's time
for President Trump to deliver on his
guarantee with regard to the wall was
time for Republicans to stand tall in
the face of democratic threats to shut
down the government let the Democrats
shut down funding for seniors because
they want to make sure that there's no
border security let's have that
political battle these are all political
battles that can be fought and won but
they cannot be fought in one every if
there's a distraction every time now
President Trump can get away with being
a distracting guy he can get away with
tweeting stuff about the NFL but when it
comes to other elections people don't
take crap the way they do in a
presidential in a presidential the
stakes are so high that people's
threshold for taking crap
from their own side is incredibly high
to the same does not hold true of Senate
elections or congressional elections we
need to recognize this reality if
Republicans hope to retain any semblance
of control in Washington DC so Alabama
should be a wake up call to a lot of
people by the way it should also be a
wake-up call for Democrats that they
need a particular set of voters
particularly Obama voters if they want
to win Charles Barkley made this point
Berkeley was stumping for Doug Jones and
Alabama he's from Alabama he's a
Republican but he was stumping against
Roy Moore here is here is Charles
Barkley talking about the turnable might
for for doesn't refer out for Roy Moore
what's your message for president Trump
tonight as an Alabamian as somebody who
helped deliver the state to doug jones
what do you want President Trump to take
away from this evening well this is a
wake-up call for Democrats you're
Democrats and I told mr. Jones this and
I love Doug
they've taken the black vote and the
poor vote for granted for a long time
it's time for them to get off their ass
and start making life better for black
folks and people who are poor they've
always had our votes and they have
abused our votes and this is a wake up
call
we got it in a great position now but
this is a wake-up call for Democrats to
do better for black people and poor
white people ok so Charles Barkley
letting the Democrats know that black
votes are not always on the table for
Democrats just because they want them to
be so there are some realities that are
setting in for both sides if the sides
are willing to look at them I doubt it
either side well I think Democrats are
gonna continue to run radicals in races
where they should be running moderate
and I think that Republicans are gonna
continue to run bad candidates just
because anti-establishment and and all
the rest of this because if people
actually learn their lessons maybe our
politics would get better but I highly
doubt that that's actually going to
happen okay
in other news there's a massive piece of
breaking news that I don't know how
Robert Muller spins this away with
regards his investigation I mean this is
truly an incredible piece of news so
there's a series of text messages that
were exchanged between top FBI employees
referring to presidential candidate
Donald Trump is an idiot and a douche
well fearing his potential victory is
terrifying okay this was from Peter
Straz 'extra Kakadu Peter stroke the guy
who was removed in a
his August of this year from the Russian
counterintelligence investigation by the
FBI because of his bias he was also
involved in initiating the Russian
counterintelligence investigation and
him calling Trump an idiot or a douche I
don't think any of that makes a
difference as far as whether he can do
his job or not I think a lot of people
have called the president those names
including his own Secretary of State but
I don't think that one of these messages
is capable of explanation and I think
that it's gonna be very difficult to
explain away why stroszek was was
involved in this in this investigation
to begin with why he was allowed to
initiate this investigation begin with
if this stuff was true so on March 16th
2016 he texted his paramour Linda page
and she texted him I cannot believe
Donald Trump is likely to be an actual
serious candidate for president and
wrote back to God Trump is a loathsome
human yet he may win and then this is
the big one August 15th 2016 Razzak
tells his girlfriend Paige quote I want
to believe the path you threw out for
consideration and Andy's office that be
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe who
has significant connections to Democrats
that there's no way he gets elected but
I'm afraid we can't take that risk it's
like an insurance policy in the unlikely
event you die before you're 40 yeah what
that sounds very much like isn't it
straws ik and his girlfriend that basic
is mistress that basically they were
initiating investigations into Trump as
an insurance policy in case Trump would
win that is shocking stuff okay that's
much more of a smoking gun than anything
I've seen in the Trump investigation to
target president Trump according to CNN
as the former number-two official in
counterintelligence Stronach helped lead
the FBI's investigation of Hillary
Clinton's private email server and was
involved in opening the investigation
into Russian meddling in the 2016 US
presidential election Paige was also
briefly on Muller's team before
returning to the FBI but she completed
her detail before the special counsel's
office was made aware of the texts so in
other words two of the people who were
involved in key ways in both the Hillary
investigation and the Trump
investigation were not only biased
against Trump they were openly talking
about setting up an insurance policy
with the FBI deputy director in case
Trump were to be elected I mean that is
shocking shocking stuff that's the sort
of stuff that kills an investigation
hey-oh yesterday I was sort of mocking
the idea of a special investigation of
the special investigation not mocking it
anymore okay based on that text it seems
to me that there should be some sort of
real
vestigation that goes on into exactly
how the special investigation is
conducting its business all of this
could be setting up Trump to fire the
members of Muller's team or to fire
Muller himself on the basis of this I
can't say that would be completely
illegitimate I think it'd be a bad
political move I think would be unwise
for the president to do that but it
would not be completely illegitimate
this does not look like a team and that
was designed to get to the bottom of
things it looks like a team that was
designed to dig in zig and dig until
they find something that they can use
politically against the President of the
United States or at least that's what
some people on the team we're looking
for now Muller got rid of Strauss ik
when he found out about these texts but
the damage is already done you know in
in evidence there's something called in
legal evidence there's something called
fruit of the poisonous tree doctrine the
idea is that if I don't have a warrant
to search inside your house and I just
break into your house I'm a cop I break
in your house and I find a murder weapon
that murder weapon is not admissible in
court because it's quote-unquote fruit
of the poisonous tree I broke the law in
order to go into your house and now I
can't admit that evidence in court even
though it would help convict you okay
this is very similar even if this
investigation were to come up with
something it's difficult to tell whether
it was it we came up with it through
bias or whether it was come up with
through actual investigation and right
now I haven't seen any evidence at all
that's been presented that Trump was
involved in Russia collusion apparently
the period that's being focused on now
in the investigation he's the period
after Trump was elected which doesn't
sound like election collusion with the
Russians to me so the this investigation
is spiraling out of control I think
President Trump knows it and it's
frustrating him and I think rightly so
also the media's continual focus on
President Trump and trying to nitpick
him it is calling 90% of all of the
coverage on TV of President Trump has
been negative so far that probably
contrasted 90% that was positive so far
in Obama's presidency and as the
evidence of just how bad the media are I
need to talk a little bit about this
blow up they happen with Kirsten
Gillibrand yesterday I mentioned it
yesterday that President Trump knocked
Kirsten Gillibrand the senator from New
York
after Gillibrand suggested that
President Trump should step down from
his position because of sexual
harassment or abuse allegations and
Trump tweeted back at her and he said
something like you know she would come
into your office on her knees to beg for
things right this is a woman who'd bet
who'd do anything to beg and the
democrats said all this is crazy
Trump is making a sexual sexual
reference to Kirsten Gillibrand hey
Trump has said exactly the same thing
about Mitt Romney like word for word
about Mitt Romney but that didn't stop
the
Kratts in the media from running with
this false narrative there's kirsten
gillibrand playing the wounded innocent
in all of us were you offended by the
apparent insinuations and the
president's tweets this morning it was a
sexist smear attempting to silence my
voice and I will not be silenced on this
issue neither will the women who stood
up to the president yesterday and
neither will the millions of women who
have been marching since the women's
March to stand up against policies they
do not agree with if you'll permit me a
follow-up do you see this as sexual
harassment by tweet I see it as a sexist
smear I mean that's what it is and okay
so again this is one of the ways the
Democrats are gonna overplay their own
head I say I talked about Democrats
losing now they may not lose
congressional elections but Kirsten
Gillibrand is not gonna win against
Donald Trump on the basis that this is a
sexist smear because it was not a sexist
smear I think that the White House was
exactly right when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders got mocked yesterday for saying
this I think she was 100% correct she
was asked by the press about the
so-called sexist smear against Kirsten
Gillibrand and here's what she here's
what she had to say she said get your
minds out of the gutter
if your mind is in the gutter would you
read it that way and so no it's not it
was open and it was not mind obviously
talking about political partisan games
that people often play and the broken
system that he's talked about repeatedly
this isn't new this isn't a new
sentiment this isn't new terminology
he's used it several times before as I
said a few minutes ago he's used it
several times before referencing men of
both both parties in fact okay so she is
exactly correct the media went nuts over
nothing and this is why Trump continues
to befuddle his opponents he can be
funnel his opponents but it doesn't drip
down to the lower levels and this is one
of the problems only Trump can be Trump
only Trump is capable of being Trump if
Trump wants to govern he's going to need
more than Trump in order to do that
there's more than one branch of the
federal government okay so now if you
want to watch the rest of the show
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire calm you can check
cast out over a daily wear icon for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of our
show live to get the rest of Manitou
Clavin show live we get the rest of
Michael Mosley's show live it gets to be
part of our mailbag which will be doing
on Friday this week you got to be part
yesterday if you're a member of the
conversation ask me live questions and
get all of your life's questions
answered which is pretty awesome if you
got the annual subscription you get all
of those wondrous glories plus you get
this the very finest and all beverage
vessels the leftist tier is hot or cold
tumbler you will enjoy it honestly if
you want if you're gonna subscribe to it
now and get the tumbler because I'm not
sure how much longer we're gonna be
using the tumblers the giveaway so if
we're if you want to get the annual
subscription for $99 a year it is less
expensive than the monthly subscription
it also makes a terrific Christmas gift
for folks make sure that you give your
family a laugh and also a terrific
tumbler that they can humiliate their
co-workers with that's that's what it's
for so go over to daily wire comm and
subscribe right now if you just want to
listen later go over to SoundCloud
iTunes where tune in wherever it is that
you download our podcast and make sure
that you subscribe as well over there
and we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
okay so meanwhile the Republicans are
trying to rush this tax bill through the
details on the tax bill are not
particularly clear at this point they
say that they have a deal so I guess
this thing is gonna get passed according
to the New York Times the deal is
already on the table the Republicans are
gonna be making the corporate tax rate
twenty one percent I guess is the final
deal here this is the New York Times
reporting they say that the details on
the deal we're not immediately available
excuse me on Tuesday Republicans said
they were close to agreement on a
package that included a cut in the
corporate tax rate to 21 percent from a
high of 35 percent and reducing the top
income tax rate for individuals to 37%
from 39.6% all of this would be good
it's not clear for Republican senators
would get behind the deal one of the big
problems with not having Luthor strange
in the Senate is that Republicans are
gonna be down to 51 votes that means the
basically john mccain and one friend can
tank any tax deal that is that is done
here or susan collins and lisa murkowski
or Susan Collins and John McCain 52
votes a lot better than 51 votes but
that's why you shouldn't run piece of
garbage candidates it's so they're
saying that you know both Susan Collins
of Maine and Marco Rubio of Florida are
raising concerns Collins says she's not
in favor of the lower individual tax
rate and Rubio wants a more generous
child tax credit I'm sort of split on
the child tax credit myself I got to be
honest with you number one I think that
the idea that it incentivizes people to
have kids it's just not sure I don't
think anybody sits around they go you
know what I really need a child tax
credit I'm gonna have this baby now
it may alleviate some financial need for
people with kids which I guess is good
but I don't think the government should
be picking and choosing which behaviors
to push with tax policy I think there
should be a basically a flat tax rate
without the government trying to make
these sorts of considerations the Senate
bill narrowly passed 5149 with bob
corker voting against the legislation
the agreement was finalized Wednesday
morning hours before the first and only
scheduled public meeting of the
Congressional conference committee
formed to work out the differences
between the House and Senate past
versions of the bill so we will see what
the final bill looks like it is a bill
that moves the ball in the right
direction I believe that they are set to
to keep the the removal of the
individual mandate in Obamacare which is
good
because nobody should be forced to buy
health insurance it will increase the
price of health insurance for sick
people in the individual market across
the country that's why the Republicans
are seeking to backfill that by
basically funding all of those those
health insurance programs directly which
may or may not be good policy bottom
line is it will be a major victory for
President Trump president Trump will
deserve kudos for it
Republicans will deserve will deserve
kudos for it they need to get another
couple of victories under their belts if
they really want to succeed in 2018 and
not get blown out okay time for some
things I like things I hate and then a
quick Bible talk so first been doing
Beethoven all week so people have heard
this music but they don't know what it
is from it is from the puffit eke sonata
the piano sonata by Beethoven this is
the second movement of the paths of the
puffit eke sonata by Beethoven his piano
sonatas are all great I actually prefer
the apassionata to the to the pathetique
but if we are doing a sort of well known
Beethoven that you don't know what it's
from this is what it is wrong
[Music]
it's just amazing music one of the
things about Beethoven that's it's
really fascinating is that he's
underrated as a melodic composer because
his because his development sections are
so good and in classical music very
often in classical music is structured
like you play a melody and then there's
a development section then there's a
recapitulation meaning that you go back
to the melody at the end I his
development sections are always very
complex and very interesting but and
very tight usually even though he writes
much longer music than a lot of other
classical composers if you look at a
typical Beethoven symphony beyond the
third the Eroica which really
revolutionised symphonies the first
movement of the Eroica is longer than
entire Mozart symphonies but his his
melodic gift is still very much in
evidence I won't say that that
Beethoven's melodies are as memorable as
Mozart's as a general rule Mozart is
gifted with melody Tchaikovsky uniquely
gifted with melody but Beethoven's
melodies are moving and there's certain
subtlety to them that doesn't
necessarily exist in Mozart or
Tchaikovsky they're less showy but
they're a little bit more spiritual okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
now it is important I guess to to the
left that even Barbie dolls have a
political agenda so first we heard for
years the Barbie dolls make little girls
feel inferior about their bodies again I
have not met these little girls my my
sisters like playing with Barbies
particularly my second sister I've three
was a big Barbie doll acolyte she had
like entire boxes and Barbie dolls and
never at any point did she say well I
wish I look like Barbie like I don't
know the idea that that little girls
were sitting around getting anorexic
because they saw Barbie doll I always
thought that kind of stuff was stupid I
really don't think that's the case I
think that if you're gonna look to the
reasons for people having body
dysmorphia and body image issues it has
very little to do with Barbie and a lot
more to do with popular advertising and
or parental failures but now there's
head-turn Barbie into a sin to a social
justice warrior so writer Elizabeth C
grant wrote an article for Fast Company
in which she said just before
Thanksgiving this year Barbie had her
woke esthetical Barbie style Instagram
channel she was pictured in a series of
photos with another doll a me wearing
t-shirts emblazoned with Love Wins the
slogan of the marriage equality movement
barbie is a doll it's an inanimate
object Barbie didn't do anything the
people who work at Mattel did something
and the people working
did that because they felt like catering
to a particular political audience
politicizing children's toys is really
unpleasant people it's unpleasant okay
making my three and a half year old
daughter think about lesbianism at
three-and-a-half seems to me a bad move
maybe this is heteronormative
I don't care you know why because I
think that it is better for young girls
to be thinking along the lines of
eventual marriage to men than it is for
them to think that they can marry anyone
I think it is better for society I think
it is better for civilization now they
may turn out to be a lesbians right a
little girl may turn out to be a lesbian
that's okay I don't really have a
problem with that what I do have a
problem with is the idea that society is
going to suggest that all sexual
orientations have equal impact on
children or that all children should be
taught about a variety of sexual
orientations before they even have
sexual feelings or are confused about
sexual feelings confusing children is a
form of sin in my mind and adults are
fond of doing it now they're using
children's toys to do it in one pair in
one of these pictures the parent said in
cozily in Barbie's walk-in closet
stroking the dog and staring into each
other's eyes and another they're eating
avocado toast at their favorite
Silverlake cafe so good news Barbies now
a lesbian which I'm sure makes more men
than women happy actually but that's not
enough in September a Barbie style
Instagram account featured Barbie luring
the people are people t-shirt designed
by Christian Siriano
to protest president Trump's immigration
ban so now Barbies an immigration
activist which again it's an inanimate
object why should my three and a half
year old be taught about immigration
policy this is just stupid protection
and protecting children and in the
innocence of children means protecting
them from having to think about issues
where they are they've not been informed
about any of the background and then
have no capacity to make decent
decisions on these things we don't allow
five-year-olds to vote okay let's put
this way the target audience for your
product is not capable of making a
rational decision about a topic don't
present them the information on the
topic ok don't present them the illusion
that they're capable of making a
rational decision about this you're
setting a bias in the background I just
think that's wrong ok so now for a quick
Bible study so in the aftermath of
Alabama a lot of Republicans are
understandably very upset I'm upset too
I am NOT THERE there are some people who
are chortling this morning on the on the
conservative side of the I am certainly
not one of them I am very deeply on
happy that the the senator from Alabama
is now a Democrat I think that's
terrible for the country I think it
would have been terrible in very
different ways of Remora had an elected
senator from Alabama sometimes the
choice between hepatitis and cancer
means that everyone is basically going
to be disease-ridden but I think that we
should take some solace in the Bible
there's a lot of talk about Bible
surrounding this election and it seems
like there's very little reference to
the actual text of the Bible so this is
from Isaiah 30 and I think this should
be of some comfort this is a situation
in which I've talked about it a couple
times on the program in which Isaiah was
urging the king of Israel Hezekiah not
to side with the Egyptians against the
Assyrians to basically allow events to
take their course and here's what Isaiah
said he said therefore this is what the
Holy One of Israel says because you have
rejected this message relied on
oppression dependent on deceit this sin
will become for you like a high wall
cracked and bulging that collapses
suddenly in an instant it will break in
pieces like pottery shattered so
mercilessly that among its frat it's
pieces not a fragment will be found for
taking coals from a hearth or scooping
the water out of a cistern this is what
the sovereign Lord the Holy One of
Israel says in repentance and rest is
the other salvation in quietness and
Trust is your strength but you would
have none of it okay you said no we will
flee on horses therefore you will flee
you said we'll ride off on Swift horses
therefore your pursuers will be swept a
thousand will flee at the threat of one
I have the threat of five you all flee
away till you are left like a Flagstaff
on the mountaintop like a banner on a
hill yet the Lord longs to be gracious
to you therefore he'll rise up to show
you compassion for the Lord is a God of
justice blessed are all who wait for him
it doesn't mean that God's gonna make
all your decisions for you what it does
mean is that when you hold true to godly
values and I and what I mean by this is
not lying to yourself not pretending
away moral conflicts when you hold true
to godly values no matter what decision
you make when you have that foremost in
your mind you are not abandoning God you
are abandoning God when you suggest that
you're gonna put your faith in men
they're gonna put your faith in bad men
that you think that the only thing that
you can do now is is a choice between a
bad man and another bad man as opposed
to waiting it out I just don't think
that's the case we're only gonna have a
better day in this country when we all
realize that there are better people on
the horizon so long as we can wait for
them and more than that more importantly
than that that if we abide by the values
that God instills in us if we abide by
blaa caliz
in terms of how we treat our fellow man
and how we vote
our fellow man then perhaps God will
bring about a better day when the
candidates that we vote for are actually
worthy of our votes okay we'll be back
here tomorrow with more fallout I'm sure
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2017